[Music]
robert is with us in california hey
robert welcome to the ramsey show
hello um
yeah so my question is very related to
ken's book that he's been working on and
basically i have two job offers
both really good offers but one of them
is substantially higher than the other
and
the one that's higher is working for a
really big tech corporation um that i
wouldn't necessarily be super excited
about uh and the one that's lower is a
job i'd be much more excited about but
it's a lot lower it's like uh seventy
thousand dollars less so i'm wondering
what are the two numbers
uh it's like
240 total compensation versus 170.
doing what
software development for the tech
corporation what's the other option the
170 240 and 170
yeah but what's the what kind is it both
tech jobs tech development yeah they're
both software which one's a big company
yeah they're both they're both software
development but the the smaller uh the
lower one of the smaller company that's
doing work that i think is actually
interesting where i would be much more
excited to like go to my job every day
as opposed to
exactly all right so let's ask this
question for that company
you're more excited is there a ladder
what does it look like a year two three
years down the line if you take the 170
doing the work that you're interested in
so they've definitely assured me that
there's a ladder but it's a little
harder to find information on how much
of a ladder there is because the
companies the the lower salary one that
i'm more excited about is only a year
and a half old as a company so there's
not a lot of information on how the
ladder's been for other people yeah what
do you make currently you've got two
offers what are you currently making
i currently make about 130 so they're
both they're both
increases obviously one's a huge
increase so yeah let me ask you this if
if both of them were the same pay which
one would you choose
oh i would definitely choose the smaller
company by far if they're the same day
so to me though this is the advice i
give dave may disagree and he wouldn't
be wrong uh but i have talked to enough
people on the ken coleman show and the
ramsay show that have taken the
promotion or taken an offer that was
more money and they'll call me back and
they'll say i took it
and i'm miserable now or i don't have
the meaning i wish i was doing the other
work and i think that you've got to
remove the money from the equation
because you're not going backwards on
either and you've got to say what is it
that i want to do why do i enjoy option
two
more than option one and if there is a
ladder it seems that there is i'm always
gonna say
follow your heart and do the work that
you're excited about if there is a
ladder and it sounds like there so
that's where i would go because i think
money's not enough to sustain you
completely agree only i'm going to do a
modified option one i'm going to go back
in and go guys
my heart is here this is what i want to
do i love what you're doing i want to be
plugged in i got this other offer for
240.
yeah
help me help me figure out a way to come
here
yeah so i mean they probably they're not
going to go to 240. i didn't say that
yeah i didn't say you had to match it i
just said help me figure out a way to
come here
and then they you know and it could it
could be that they very clearly outline
a detailed ladder on a calendar
it could be that they offer you stock
options in this startup that are worth a
whole heck of a lot more than 70.
right that's true they could give you
some points in the deal what the stock
is going to be worth you take you a
couple deal points and and you take this
job yeah but you go back in and you ju
you just smile and you just say i really
want to come here help me figure out a
way
right that's a great point and then just
let them squirm and start answering that
question that don't you don't tell them
what the answer is
and here's what's going to happen a
they're going to give you a more more
than 170. b they're going to offer a
ladder or something like that and c they
may even offer you points in the deal
and none of those are on the table today
and
one simple question shut up
let this let the let the pressure fall
in the room on the other side of the
table
gently kindly say
i really want to come here
these other people are offering me 240.
help me figure out a way to come
and i promise you it will not result in
anything but more money in this
conversation it's a wonderful
negotiating tool it'll work for it'll
just just hey man that phone call's
worth 20 grand shut up and this show's
free
there you go
you don't get this anywhere else in
america i can tell you that